il faut d'abord
nominé mais n'agit pas détourné 10
juillet
encore rêver
régnier mais non tu vas d'autre part on
est tous
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre émission
nout cars jaunes des missions qui vous
parle du réseau car l'homme à travers
ceux qui y travaillent et ceux qui les
utilisent
car c'est ce lien tissé au fil des
années à travers toute la réunion qui
constitue l'âme de cars jaunes souvenez
vous
c'est dans les années 20 qui est apparu
le premier transport en commun routier
les fameux quart courants d'air comme il
ne proposait que douze places on s'en
passait alors sont ils marchent pieds et
même sur le toit
ils vont ensuite évolué pour accueillir
jusqu'à 40 personnes et pouvait rouler
jusqu'à 100 kilomètres heure certains
modèles fonctionner même avec un
carburant locale à base d'alcool de
cannes et d'essence au fil du temps ils
seront progressivement remplacés pour
laisser la place aux quarts que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
en 1982 le principe de droit au
transport pour tous est appliquée les
départements prennent alors en charge
l'organisation des services réguliers
public de transports routiers non
urbains de personnes en 1988
le département propose le réseau alizée
premier réseau structurant est le
précurseur du réseau car jaune qui verra
le jour en 1996 en 1997 les premiers
points de vente sont ouverts les réseaux
locaux qui car jaune voit le jour et des
premières cartes mensuelles d'abonnement
sont mises en place avec cest pour les
moins de 26 ans et jaune pour lui plus
de 26 ans le dispositif chèque transport
est opérationnel quant à lui dès 1998 en
janvier 2001 la carte de carambole
propose une réduction de 50% pour les
demandeurs d'emploi puis le numéro azur
est mis à disposition des usagers dès
2003 à partir de 2004 de nombreuses
actions améliore de manière sensible
l'accès au réseau car jaune et la notion
de cohésion sociale fait son apparition
les lignes et claire sont créés cette
même année accompagné une baisse des
tarifs sur l'ensemble du réseau et des
premiers carnets de tickets
dans la foulée le dispositif anciens
combattants et systématiser et des
lignes dédiées sont mises à disposition
des étudiants puis en 2005 la carte on
passe est proposé aux personnes à
mobilité réduite
la fréquentation du réseau ne cesse de
croître depuis lors et l'on peut
considérer sans craindre de se tromper
qu à ce jour le réseau car jaune fait
partie intégrante du patrimoine
réunionnais c'était la rencontre de ce
patrimoine et surtout de ceux qui le
font que nous vous proposons de partir
chaque semaine
bonjour je m'appelle de munich j'habite
à sainte suzanne et j'ai 49 ans et je
vais sur le fond la deuxième fois que je
prends le cas
j'ai changé de
le mode 2
des déplacements par rapport aux le
matin c'est l'esprit sans prendre la
voiture
il faut tout calculer avec les enfants
le travail est un travail de madame et
est le mien donc c'était pas du tout
compatible
au début c'est que bon et ça fait deux
ans qu'on est à la marine donc on a
construit ont travaillé sur le pommeau à
damier noir et
comme moi je prenais très tôt le matin à
6h15
donc j'ai demandé à moduler mais aurait
travail d'entre eux maintenant je me
retrouve à cette rentrée à 7 heures le
matin et comme madame elle prend
8 heures maintenant elle aussi elle a eu
un changement d'horaires donc elle va
reprendre à 9h30
je réalise que prendre le bus c'est
mieux pour moi
pour moi c'est en haut car si mitt
romney car jaune depuis bientôt une
bonne quinzaine d'années quand je viens
travailler le matin et je rentre le soir
je suis bien content de la journée et je
n'oublie pas aussi me
mes enfants mes deux garçons ma fille
que
que j'aime beaucoup
et reposant oui c'est moins stressant
bon et puis c'est par rapport aussi mes
enfants aussi donc
le matin parties à travailler avec les
enfants c'est pas évident c'est comme
eux il rentre à 8 heures est pas évident
du tout
on est sur des services avec roulements
donc on peut comprendre comment c'est
une semaine à 4 heures 4 heures du matin
le premier service et à 4h 85
il se termine au plus tard en 21h30 ce
soir depuis l'âge de 8 ans j'ai commencé
à prendre le cas au début avec mes
frères mais après dans la continuité
j'ai j'ai continué à prendre le car de
chez moi
barrage jusqu'à saint paul moi ce que ce
que je monte c'est que il faut que quand
on fait le travail
les clients sont satisfaits de mon côté
je suis moins stressé le matin fait
écouter madame voilà un gain de temps
pour s'occuper des enfants ou garder les
enfants qui vont à l'école
j'ai une petite qui a un ennemi
et de l'été deux garçons présents 13 ans
dix ans et voilà je trouve que bon ça
arrange tout le monde
je voulais c'est pour prendre mon
service et bonne journée